نعم ليلى بالفعل كنا قد رصدنا لحظه وصول
الاسيره المحرره مرح بكير التي كانت في
سجون الاحتلال لثماني سنوات لكن شرطه
الاحتلال منعت حتى البقاء خارج المنزل
ساشير قبل ان انتقل لمرح الى ان البيت
خالي تماما من الاقرباء من الاصدقاء من
الجيران من المهنئين وذلك وفقا للشروط
والقيود التي حددتها شرطه الاحتلال
العائله تم اقتحام هذا المنزل ومنازل باقي
الاسيرات في مدينه القدس المحتله واجبر من
كان قد وصل من الاقرباء من الدائره
المقربه جدا للعائلات
لاستقبال الاسيرات تم طردهم بالقوه ومنعهم
من البقاء في هذه المنازل حتى تهنئه
الاسيرات منعت في القدس حاولوا بطبيعه
الحال اغتيال لحظات الفرح لكن يعني لو
شاهدنا فقط صوره ام مرح ومرح وربما من
تابع معنا عصر هذا اليوم لقائنا مع ام مرح
قبل الافراج عن مرح لا ادرك الفرق يعني
بين الام التي بكت طيله هذا النهار وطله
الثمان سنوات عمليا وبين صورتها الان
وابنتها مرح في حضنها الحمد لله بسلامتكم
مره ثانيه يا ربي وقلت لكم نحنا اليوم خلص
احنا رجعت الفرحه برجعه مرح وكل البكا ال
بكنا كت عشان مرح مش موجوده معنا
واها
وور مبسوطين انها رجعت كثير ون كنا متفقين
ان احنا ننام كلنا اليوم مع بعض فحنا راح
ننام كلنا اليوم مع بعض على نفس تخذ ا
جنبي لانه ثمان سنين كثير و لس طفله وهي
بتزعل كنت احكي لها طفله بس هي ل طفلتنا
المدلله يعني يعني الطفله اللي عمرها 24
سنه الحمدلله بسلامتك الله يسلم مرح
احكينا بالاول عن شعورك اليوم وعن شو
تركتي وراك في
السجن شوفي زي ما حكيت برجع باكد يعني
المشاعر عن جد مختلطه كثير وانا مخربطه
كثير بس بنفس الوقت كثير سعيده وكثير عن
جد فرحانه كثير عن جد من قلبي انه انا صرت
برا يعني لانه بالنهايه هذا حق كل اسير
واسير ان هم يمارسوا حياتهم الطبيعيه
بعيدا عن جو السجون بعيدا عن عالم السجون
الظالم بحكي لك شو تركت وراي انا يعني
طلعت من سب يعني عزلوني من سب عش وما بعرف
شو وضع القسم بس انا هلا بعرف انه في 83
اسيره جوا القسم احنا قسمنا ما بوسع غير
51 اسيره وهلا الاسيرات حرفين حرفين اذا
نيجي نحكي بالعميه فوق بعض يعني حرفيا
الشي مش مقبول بالمره في غرف توسعه اربعه
فيها ع يعني مش فارق معهم بالمره الاداره
وين يحطوا وين يحطوا البنات في تنكيل كثير
بتم التعامل مع البنات بطريقه سيئه كثير
اليوم كمان عرفت شي كثير يعني انا بعتبره
بصراحه خطير على الحركه الاسيره النسويه
لقدام لما اعتقلوا كمان كثير بنات من
الداخل ومن الضفه اي هلا الاسيرات القدام
هم عمليا رح يروحوا اليوم نحن روحنا ست
اسيرات من القدس و1 اسيره تقريبا من الضفه
وغدا كمان ان شاء الله رح يتم الافراج عن
الباقي الناس الاقدمين الناس اللي الضاي
اول شيء الاداره حكت عنه ان هي ما رح يتم
التعامل معهم زي ما تم التعامل معنا من
قبل فواضح انه ه رح يكون في تنكيل كثير
كبير هذا الشيء بيدل على خطر كثير كبير
على الاسيرات قادم عن جد انا بطلب من
الجميع انه ما حدا يترك الاسيرات لانه
اللي جاي لقدام ما رح يكون سهل بالمره